we're now less than three months from
apple's annual september event where
they're expected to release the brand
new iphone 13
and so far there are some pretty massive
expectations
due to the large amount of leaks and
rumors starting to spread around
but unfortunately we just got updated
with some new ones
that are actually really disappointing
because some of the new features that
we've been waiting for
seem to be getting delayed once again so
in this video
i'm gonna cover exactly what to expect
for the next iphone
so you'll know if it's going to be worth
waiting for or not first up i want to go
through some recent leaks in the supply
chain that show that everything is still
on track
for a september release date unlike last
year when the iphones were revealed in
october because of the pandemic
almost two weeks ago regulatory filings
for the new iphone 13 models
were discovered online and if you don't
know what that means
apple is basically required by russia to
register all products containing
encryption tools before they can
actually go up for sale and start
shipping
this ironically forces apple to leak
their own products before they actually
get released
but lucky for them not that much info is
actually revealed
except for the type of product on top of
that digitimes recently reported that
iphone 13 chipmakers
are scaling up production in the third
quarter of this year
which begins in july pointing to
everything going as planned
in fact an analyst from wedbush says
that the new iphones will be announced
in the third week of september
likely on september 14th which makes a
ton of sense
since last year the september event was
held on the 15th
and on top of that foxconn the main
manufacturer of iphones
is apparently offering record high
signing bonuses
for the peak iphone season in order to
ensure that they have enough workers to
meet demand and of course
as we all know we're in the middle of a
very deep chip
shortage that's impacting basically
everything from cars to graphics cards
and everything else
but thankfully we just got a new report
from digitimes.tsmc
the company that makes every single
apple silicon ship
is gonna be prioritizing chip orders
from apple as well as car manufacturers
which is excellent news for us because
we're less likely to see delays
and more specifically they're preparing
the new five nanometer plus process
for the iphone 13's a15 chip
which is going to further improve
performance and efficiency now getting
into the actual features that we should
be expecting
we've recently got a few bits of bad
news but before i get into that
i want to quickly update everyone on the
new features that we were expecting
before the latest rumors came out as far
as the lineup
we're expecting the same four models as
the iphone 12
including the mini which is selling so
badly right now
that apple has apparently stopped
production of the 12 mini completely
so it's surprising to see apple give it
another go with the iphone 13 mini
all of the new iphones are expected to
come with a smaller notch
a built-in touch id sensor larger
batteries
120 hertz pro motion displays for the
pro models
with always on displays as well as an
upgraded ultra wide camera lidar
scanners on all of the new iphones
up to one terabyte of storage wi-fi 6e
and more but according to some of the
latest reports from trend force and
matriquo
the new iphone 13s are definitely not
going to be as exciting as we previously
expected
first off that one terabyte of storage
rumor doesn't seem to be happening this
year
with trendforce saying that the iphone
13 pro models
will still be limited to the same 512
gigs of storage
on top of that while the new iphones
will have a smaller notch
which is definitely a long-awaited
upgrade the exterior design
in general is set to look basically the
same
as the iphone 12s sony dixon actually
shared an image of the new iphone 13
dummy models
and as you can see the pro models on the
left look almost
identical to the current iphone 12
except that the camera bumps are quite a
bit larger but if you look at the less
expensive models on the right
you can see that the lens orientation is
now diagonal instead of vertical
so apple's likely just doing that to mix
it up
and make it obvious that it's the new
iphone 13. going even further
the lighter scanner which was previously
expected to come
on all of the new models is now only
expected to come
on the pro models according to trend
force
and this actually makes a lot of sense
because it's one of the current
exclusive features
that is really tempting because it
really does help portrait
photos turn out quite a bit nicer than
before moving on
there's a good chance that the iphone 13
could actually be called the iphone 12s
based on rumors from sam cole as well as
john prosser
who says that the number 13 is seen as
very negative
in certain cultures on top of that mark
german stated that apple internally
considers the 2021 iphone to be an s
upgrade because apple isn't really
planning any major
changes and john prosser believes that
the only major changes will be a smaller
notch
120 hertz and an under display
fingerprint scanner for touch id
so based on that and info from his
sources it'll likely be called the
iphone 12s now to me this totally makes
sense because there are actually hotels
out there
that will avoid having a 13th floor
because of the superstition so there's a
chance that apple will completely skip
13
and go straight to the iphone 14 next
year
which would be a bit weird but it
definitely is likely to happen
now this next report from mainstream quo
that just came out yesterday
is perhaps the most disappointing of all
apparently the under display touch of
the sensor
is only expected to come next year on
the 2022 iphone lineup
which really sucks because there are
many people who have been waiting for
this feature
for a while and samsung's had this in
their phones
for many years already but what's very
interesting is that quo says that the
mini model
will be replaced with a budget version
of the large
6.7 inch iphone 12 pro max in 2022
priced at around 900. but unfortunately
it's apparently gonna lack the under
display touch id sensor
so that basically means that this new
iphone 14
max model will match the regular iphone
14 model in terms of the feature set
but it'll simply compact with the larger
display
now this is actually going to be very
nice for those people who really care
about the display
size but don't really want to pay eleven
hundred dollars
for all of those extra pro features and
in my opinion
apple is really gonna have to offer some
unique features
on the more expensive pro max model
because the new budget 900
version is gonna be very enticing for a
lot of people out there
and according to ming chi kuo the new
2022 iphones will come with a 48
megapixel camera
that can shoot 8k video and to me
it makes sense to have that camera
exclusive to
the pro models but going back to this
year's new iphone which is going to be
the iphone 12s
or the iphone 13 it's looking like it's
going to be more of a small spec
bump sort of upgrade with no real major
changes
other than the smaller notch improved
cameras and the 120hz
promotion display on the pro models now
personally to me
that 120hz feature is worth upgrading
alone
because i've been waiting for it ever
since apple brought that feature to the
ipad pro
many years ago but i have a good feeling
that a lot of the people out there are
going to be disappointed
with this year's iphone upgrade hence
why there's a good chance it'll be
called
the iphone 12s now if you totally
disagree with my thoughts on all of this
let me know down in the comment section
below but if you enjoyed this video go
ahead and click the circle above to
subscribe
for more videos like this one definitely
check out one of those two videos right
there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]